to blatantly borrow now let's make that
steal from the legendary movie of over
40 years ago that was Network I'm mad as
hell and I'm not gonna take this anymore
this week I was told what size my
lasagna ready meal should be and
lectured not to save money on
buy-one-get-one-free deals this same
bunch of hectoring Knowles otherwise
known as public health England have also
in the past told me I need to be careful
and I see paths as I could slip to eat a
prescribed number of fruit or veg and
something I'd never figured out to open
a window you and I pay three point nine
billion pounds a year to five thousand
full-time staff to produce this asinine
drivel as a result of this nannying
nonsense we've bred a generation who
faint at the first sign of snow so I'm
asking you to get your ample backside
off your chairs and you have every right
to tell me to bug off and that was a
very good for for can I tell you by an
incredible Constance paddy Chayefsky
from whom we heard in the Oscar Mayer
he wrote Network actually public health
in England you'll be delighted to hear
actually get four point three billion
EUR wait no I think the thing is here is
it's really hard to tell people you love
and I love you that they're overweight
right and so you saw I mean it's really
hard to turn to your husband for example
let's say darling when we married you
know you were 12 stone now you're 15
stone you're a tub of lard right you
know yeah of course public health
England takes now we're also Huizar
worded and we're so snowflake II we're
so terrified of using words like fat or
fat shaming actually you need you need
the government to set to the tone but
they're not setting the tone the finger
bed public health England is it's
failing
people like you know when you when you
have a society that we you tell doctors
not to tell people they're fat in case
you embarrass them are you heard them
you know we have to get tough if we
tackle it
people don't look at them parents aren't
doing the job yes I'm saying individuals
in public health England gets all this
money and they are failing miserably
because the population do you accept
that we have a problem in this country
with particular most kids with the boys
yes what would you do about it
absolutely mandate school gym class a PE
class of this folks and trying I don't
know where we'll get them from but try
and get school fields per in school for
playing kids 2x what do you do with the
adults because what you're talking about
is for children next generation I agree
but what do we do with the adults do you
really want to know what you do look
you're not gonna like this I think I've
said this before obese people who
present themselves to the NHS they get
their first treatment free and then if
you don't go on a course and lose some
weight you start paying towards your
treatment I ask and I think also there's
no point in asking the food industry to
cut any amount of fat and salt
why not it's gonna say 4.5 billion hang
on don't ask them force them to make
them cut down because because there's no
point in letting them make killer foods
and then taxes on it there's no point of
that because lots of people don't want
to be educated on food you know if if
we're gonna produce from it producing
with less killer stuff role of a
government is to try and keep its
citizens as healthy as let me finish so
what is the problem with them educating
and advising at the end of the day
nobody has to do what they're saying
it's a suggestion we've been successful
I think I wanted a but in a way I sort
of agree with Nick there's a distinction
but I think the primary role of
government is to keep its citizens safe
yeah not healthy the nation is in the
grip of binge eating and binge drinking
I think the government has to do
something 45 percent increase in
alcohol-related deaths for the over-50s
okay is a lot great you asked me do I
agree and I did though we have got a
bistro and where were you going with
that point there well what I mean well
because I
they're trying to uh what look at this
clip from the chief nutritionist at
public health England we are very used
to as a nation consuming much more than
that than we need we're worried about
about telling people what to do too much
people you know they need freedom of
choice but actually our choices are
costing the NHS a lot of money basically
think we should the government should
keep out of mostly yes I think though if
you identify a massive national problem
yes emerging and is getting worse
government has a responsibility
can we do something about this edges of
all done so brilliantly is you focused
on obese children which is quite right
okay fine but telling people to open the
window and where is it or today today's
this very de newspaper today the Sun
newspaper today public health England
here we go again urging people not to
have birthday cake with their work
colleagues instead to make a cake of
cucumber celery and I think tomatoes you
used to be quite a lot bigger I did
forty just under fifty pounds you
decided to lose all that I did now a lot
of people would like to do that but
don't do it and can't do it can yes well
you all right they find it they're
unable it's don't know it's they're not
unable to do they're unwilling isn't
that about the sort of food that we now
eat compared to the food and actually in
the case of the cake and offices I mean
we can laugh for that but it is serious
because at the end of day how many days
sick do people have off each year
because of their unhealthy choices
absurd so why wouldn't an employer want
to actually give their employees a vegan
cake without sugar there's lots of ways
you can still enjoy yourself do the
healthier ones you can see I was gonna
be
we'll see you're sitting on this time
bomb that's getting worse and that
there's a whole generation of kids can
they come through who are gonna get
worse
what is the responsibility government to
try to do some you're taking the
sunlight yes yes there is there is a
real issue of icy roads you get involved
in it you know don't wear slippy shoes
and I see but you know I mean I just
wanna go back the the the policy on
obesity is inconsistent if they had a
consistent policy it might work
you can't we keep we tell we talk but we
can't find people that fat we keep
telling fat people but it's an addiction
of disease it is not as it's a selected
it is not an addiction to its people
never be infected yeah like we both be
fat are still that still fat it smells
know what it's about no addiction in the
sense that you don't want to stop but
you can stop and we all know what you do
to lose weight [ __ ] and we can't stop it
you can government cannot make us stop
eating and that's a fact you have to
make a decision yourself to change the
way you eat or you're gonna be fat all
your life but you've been surprisingly
quiet I mean you said a degree of
support what else do you want to add to
this do you agree with Carol that most
people should be able to address
themselves without being elected by
public health England well I think it's
a pure matter of health coming together
with us unable as a country to afford
the obesity crisis it's coming there's
something with us and actually is
getting worse if one and in five kids go
to primary school obese and one in three
leaves primary school obesity it's a
serious problem it's what you're talking
about the whole nanny state is yes the
trains have been going through a part of
southeast 150 years this obviously but
we had the comb snap they actually said
you've got to think about what you've
got a stock
Aysen